Мій батько емігрував в Америку в районі 2000 року.
І десь приблизно коли мені було 23—24 роки,
я вирішив повністю переїхати в Америку.
Я живу з дівчиною родом з Перу.
Щодня на роботу вона прокидається
на пів години, на годину раніше від мене.
Це був звичайний ранок, і тут вона забігає
просто в кімнату, будить мене і каже:
«Стас, Стас, вставай, у тебе в країні почалася війна!»
Я прокинувся і кажу: «Про що ти говориш?
У нас вже війна 8 років як іде на сході України».
Але вона каже: «Та ні, у вас там міста бомблять,
літаки літають, щось жахливе твориться».
Каже: «Вставай, дивись, дзвони
рідним, питайся що там коїться».
І я вирішив, що потрібно їхати,
потрібно допомагати чим зможу.
Думав десь ходити, допомагати
волонтерам з гуманітаркою.
Щось привозити, щось кудись
возити, відвезти, і так далі.
Тоді я знав, що мій двоюрідний брат
з товаришами збираються купити
пару автомобілів для Збройних сил України.
Збирався швидко. Зі своїх речей
зібрав маленький рюкзак.
Взяв тільки найнеобхідніше: пару футболок,
якийсь светр, шкарпетки і так далі.
Чуєш, там мама дзвонить, каже, що там:
«Чого Стас трубку не бере?
Я довідки там зробила, чи що там».
Мама тобі дзвонила, а ти трубку не брав?
Я не маю її номера.
Товариш і його дядько служили під Чорнобилем.
Від них прийшов запит на автомобіль.
Попросили повнопривідний якийсь мінівен.
Збір коштів відбувався через Instagram, Telegram.
Хтось комусь скинув, хтось запостив,
що ми збираємо кошти для автомобілів.
Приєдналися місцеві підприємці,
сім'я, друзі, діаспора американська.
Через те, що у мене є можливість виїжджати
за кордон, оскільки я є громадянином Америки,
це може дуже сильно спростити ось цей весь
процес завезення автомобілів з-за кордону.
Іще соломку можеш взяти.
Так, ключі.
Ключі є.
Паспорт є.
І всі документи.
А документи на другу машину
там в машині мають бути, правда?
— Я тобі дам ключі від цієї машини.
— Так.
Мій двоюрідний брат Тарас знаходив
автомобілі або в Польщі, або в Німеччині.
Перекидав посилання своїм друзям, які живуть в
Польщі, в Варшаві, також українці, хлопці.
Вони вже там автомобілі викуповували,
приганяли їх до кордону.
Ми їхали до кордону, я перетинав пішки кордон,
забирав автомобіль і вже переганяв його в Україну.
Як правило автомобілі потрібно було шукати повнопривідні,
з високим кліренсом, з високою прохідністю.
Закривай, поїхали, щоб ми встигли
до комендантської [години].
Перший тиждень-півтора це було дуже важко і довго
через те, що були певні бюрократичні процеси.
Ці всі дозволи було дуже важко отримувати
від обласної держадміністрації,
або від військово-цивільної адміністрації.
Привіт... Здоров, все, ми вже повертаємося.
Так, завезли, все нормально.
Я вже вдома в деталях розкажу.
Всі хотіли чимось допомогти,
ніхто не міг сидіти вдома.
І тоді, коли ми привезли
два автомобіля вже в Івано-Франківськ,
нам потрібно було їх пофарбувати
в темно-зелений колір хоча би.
Купили фарбу, завезли на СТО до товариша.
Всією бандою ми прямо там і
наждачкою перетирали цю фарбу,
спочатку здирали стару, а потім вже
і малювали в темно-зелений колір.
У мене так само багато людей запитували,
чим вони  можуть бути корисні,
де вони можуть чимось допомогти.
На скільки я знаю, у нас було багато
в Івано-Франківську  пунктів
сортування гуманітарної допомоги,
багато пунктів, де плели сітки.
І хтось щось може знайти, якщо не має
можливості допомогти фінансово.
В Америці завжди Україну сприймали
як пострадянську країну,
і багато американців ще досі вважали, що це
якась там частинка Росії, чи щось начебто того.
Навпроти, зараз це вже всі прекрасно розуміють,
що це є велика держава в центрі Європи,
незалежна, зі своєю конституцією,
суверенітетом, і дуже потужною армією.
[англійською] Будьте з Україною!